you guys are always wondering how i
create videos for youtube well i'm gonna
show you guys the entire process that i
go through to create a video from
concept to shooting to editing
everything now the video that i'm
creating is a really fun project that
i'm working on with nikon
so as of now i have no idea what video
i'm gonna do i don't have an idea but i
have a theme
so the first thing that i usually do is
try to think of an idea and sometimes
that's not the easiest thing to do but
if you decide do i want to do a skit do
i want to do a music video or do i want
to do a vlog style video that kind of
helps to take you guys in the right
direction so i'm kind of thinking that i
want to create a music video but i got
to find some music first the hardest
thing about doing music videos is a lot
of the audio that you find online is
copy written so you need to find
royalty-free music to use in all of your
projects so right now i'm using a
website called istockphoto.com where it
used to be just for stock photos but
they now have audio i'm going to look
for some music to use so i finally think
that i might have found a song that i'm
going to use before i decide if i'm
gonna buy the song or not because some
of these songs are actually a little
expensive you know 25 for a track is you
know you want to be sure that you
actually want this song and just by
listening to it i can already get a
sense of what i might want to shoot i
can see myself right now
picking up the phone
calling a friend asking them if they can
hang out they're not going to be able to
hang out i get sad so i break out into
song and i start singing about how i
don't need real friends because i have
all my friends online and i'll go out
make some videos and post them on the
internet
all right so i have my song all picked
out and now i'm going to use garageband
to record some lyrics over top of the
song this is the microphone that i'm
using it's called a blue microphone it
is a snowflake mic i just open up
garageband i start recording i start
testing out different lyrics i see
what's going to work and what's not
going to work you want to be able to
hear the music in your headphones and
also be able to record at the same time
so this allows you to kind of know what
you're singing to here we go
hi all right we're here day two of
shooting this wonderful music video now
i have all my music recorded
everything's recorded in garageband
the audio's still a little rough but i
can fix all that stuff later the most
important thing is i'm going to be doing
an outside shoot so i have to take into
consideration daylight so once it gets
dark yeah obviously that's not going to
work the first thing that i'm going to
do is i'm going to
take this wonderful little notebook here
i'm going to write down all the shots
that i want to make sure that i'm
getting
just so uh things move a little smoother
all right i'm getting ready to go out
and shoot i got my gadgets all in my bag
got my iphone that's where all my music
is gonna be and i've got this beautiful
tripod right here
wonderful and it's time to go
all right so i'm getting ready to shoot
i got my nikon all set up here
um the bad part isn't doing this all by
myself so i need to use something to
focus i'm using this tree to focus
so that's where i'm gonna be standing
and
hopefully it doesn't go out of focus but
you know whatever all right here's
nothing
god
i've been trying so hard to shoot this
video and let me tell you shooting in
the third street promenade is probably
one of the worst ideas that i've ever
had because people keep stopping and
like what are you doing
what is this this camera take pictures
oh you're taking video
yes
i am taking video and i'm making a video
and i'm going to be putting it on the
internet i know i know you don't
understand so let's just not have this
discussion because this video is due
tomorrow and i have got to go back and
edit
so here's
it was me shooting myself i was dancing
right there
oh my goodness
crazy
yeah do you wanna oh do you to look in
here and make sure i'm in the frame tell
me where i am
now
yep
but only like from here up is that all
right
so the hardest part about shooting a
video all by yourself is that not only
do you look insane well that's pretty
much the bottom line is you look crazy
people keep wondering what are you doing
what are you doing why are you all alone
with the camera filming yourself making
a video
leave me alone
okay anyway
um let me get back to doing
that just be shooting yourself yeah okay
she's doing a music video it's like one
of the shots are eating a sandwich
shooting on the third street is is
really difficult because
well obviously it's just me hanging out
with my camera
and talking to yourself
what's that were you talking to yourself
yes
i was like
yeah so i think i'm officially done
shooting
this was probably one of the most
difficult shoots that i've ever done in
my entire life something that should
have taken about an hour
could have taken about an hour
has taken
well the entire day people keep thinking
that i'm a street performer so my entire
dance sequence people are trying to
throw money at me which is fine you can
throw money at me all day long but it's
not right now because i'm really really
busy and i have to get this video done
okay i'm getting ready to shoot the
other part of my friend answering the
phone so one of the hardest things is
actually trying to get a good focus um
so i'm using this as a placeholder
that's where i'm gonna sit
and then i just uh focus right here
and everything should be in focus by the
time i remove the pillow and i put
myself in place
oh boy all right so right now i'm
copying some files over i'm gonna get
ready to edit
one tip that i can give you guys is
whenever you're shooting with like these
smaller cameras or using sd cards do not
use a cheap card it might suck to go and
buy an expensive one but it's well worth
it because what happens is these cards
read and write really really slow so
when you're taking video and you're
trying to copy over it takes a really
long time
bad card
good card definitely look for the
sandusk extreme 3 series they're
definitely so much faster than
whatever the heck this is now it's the
fun part it is editing time i've already
been editing for probably about maybe
like 40 minutes
um just going through some footage
laying out everything and trying to get
all of the uh my singing matched up to
the audio so here we go
i'm going a little crazy getting my
final cut pro on
you